[Music]
i didn't
want to write an unhappy marriage
but all marriages involve different
kinds of tension different kinds of
compromise
different world views and so what i
wanted to do was
look at the fitmatic fault lines running
through their
philosophies let's be clear it's not me
it's you killing this what do you want
me to say
there's some level of assumption that
margot
is in some way along for the ride in
that moment
in this episode we get the first
real solid glimmer that
things might be otherwise
when you get told something there's a
gun at the back of your wife's head
and you actually don't care or that's
what she thinks ally was going through
she's had enough that's when she
realizes that she's gonna take the kids
life with ali is not worth it you
promise and promise but never deliver
and that's my fault but that's not
happening anymore
that's over there's always a compelling
story to be told when you're telling the
story of people who love each other but
find it hard to co-exist and when that
actually then gets to the stakes of life
and death i think it makes for great
drama
for michael and elliot i said well is
this a romantic couple we've had long
conversations of whether they're even in
love anymore
for so long it's been a function of just
survival
they both take turns using different
limbs to try and wrap their arms around
their
family and i think they have an
intuitive knowledge of how to do it
margot's main priority is her family and
melissa i think really brings out the
motherly aspects
she's like that onset all the time she's
just very kind and caring
cops are coming justin and melissa they
created a real
bond you know they really work together
immensely well working with justin is
just
incredible he's so great to just like
throw ideas off
he did a really great job at just making
everyone multi-dimensional so that
there was a lot of just subtext going on
and there will be a look between ali and
margo
and you know without even speaking that
the two of them know exactly
what to do in order to get them out of
this situation lock yourself in the
bathroom
their bond and their love is really
through the conduit of their children
and i wonder if anything ever god forbid
happened to their children whether they
would even stay together
or whether there would be a purpose to
you